intimiste par rapport à l'avenir de son
pays george bush a su rester fidèle à
ses principes tout au long de sa vie né
le 12 juin 1924 le 41e président des
états unis a au début était
essentiellement loyal à sa famille et
surtout à son père un banquier un
sénateur qui lui a transmis le goût du
sport et de la compétition
george bush restera bien sûr loyal à sa
patrie qu'il défendra alors qu'il n'a
que 18 ans il deviendra le plus jeune
pilote de la guerre du pacifique
il effectuera 58 missions aériennes et
devra se parachuter de son appareil en
feu au dessus de l'île de chichishima
recueillis par un sous-marin américain
il sera décoré pour acte de bravoure
la guerre finie il s'inspire l'économie
à l'université de yale il se marie avec
barbra pc par pour le texas
là bas il fonde sa propre compagnie de
pétrole et devient rapidement
millionnaire mais c'est surtout la
politique qui l'attirent en 1966 il est
élu représentant républicain au congrès
des états unis et ils se retrouvent dans
l'entourage de richard nixon qui sera
lui élu président du pays deux ans plus
tard en 1970 george bush se présentent
au sénat mais il mord la poussière aux
mains du candidat démocrate
une défaite qui aurait pu se traduire
par l'abandon sa carrière politique
mais encore une fois sa loyauté le
servir à richard nixon lui demande de
devenir ambassadeur des états unis
auprès des nations unies
un poste intenable car le pays est
empêtrée dans la guerre du vietnam
george bush demande alors d'être relevé
de ses fonctions
il assume ensuite la direction du parti
républicain une mission particulièrement
délicate puisqu'il sera à la tête du
parti pendant toute la période du
watergate
mais le scandale prend de telles
proportions que george bush le fidèle
allié du président se voit obligé de lui
demander de démissionner pour le bien du
pays
gerald ford succède alors à ray charles
george bush espère devenir son
vice-président mais cela ne se fera pas
ford l'envoi plutôt assumer les
fonctions d'ambassadeur en chine et par
la suite il lui offre la direction de la
cia
lorsque la présidence du démocrate jimmy
carter prend fin george bush se présente
en 1980 à l'investiture du parti
républicain modérés favorables à
l'avortement ainsi qu'à l'égalité des
hommes et des femmes dans l'emploi
il perd aux mains de l'ancien gouverneur
de californie ronald reagan qui avait su
canaliser les nouvelles forces
conservatrices du pays
mais bush adoptera des points de vue
plus conservateurs au moment où il
deviendra le colistier de hegel devenu
le numéro deux du pays il témoignera
d'une loyauté effacé envers le président
au point où ses adversaires le présente
comme la pâle doublure de ronald reagan
ce n'est qu'après les deux mandats du
vieux président que george bush pour
approuver aux américains qu'il peut
assumer lui même ce rôle qui l'avait
tant désiré
profitant de son expérience sur la scène
internationale c'est surtout dans sa
politique étrangère qui pourra
véritablement s'affirmer il va
contribuer à la réduction de l'arsenal
nucléaire mondial et jouera adroitement
des susceptibilités engendrés par la fin
de la guerre froide
c'est sous sa présidence que le
communisme va s'effondrer le deuil avec
20 à la tête d'une coalition
internationale
george bush conduire à une guerre contre
l'irak un saddam hussein qui a envahi qu
il en sortira victorieux ce qui
permettra sa popularité d'atteindre des
sommets
brillant en politique étrangère george
bush s'est néanmoins montré faible en
politique intérieure
la seule qui importe pour les lecteurs
américains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
impossible pour lui de tenir cette
fameuse promesse de ne pas augmenter les
impôts des particuliers
car pendant sa présidence économies des
états unis s'est passablement détérioré
le déficit s'est considérablement accrue
et le chômage également sans parler des
problèmes de sécurité de criminalité qui
ont aussi augmenté en janvier 1992 ils
seront au japon à la tête d'une
délégation économique une tournée que
les observateurs qualifient d' humiliant
fiasco il s'affaisse même pendant un
dîner d'état
ce que l'on retiendra surtout de sa
présidence et que george bush fut le
premier président américain à mener son
pays dans un nouvel ordre international
avec la chute de l'union soviétique les
états unis deviennent la seule
superpuissance
sur le plan intérieur ce sont vingt cinq
millions d'américains qui se trouvent au
chômage à la fin de sa présidence
un bilan qui l'empêchera d'être réélu et
qui permettra aux démocrates de
reprendre le pouvoir
huit ans plus tard il aura quand même le
bonheur de voir son fils devenir lui
aussi président des états unis à acheter
il est atteint de la maladie de
parkinson qui le contraint à se déplacer
en fauteuil roulant en avril 2018 il
assiste avec un millier d'invités aux
funérailles de sa femme barbara
leur mariage est la plus longue union
présidentiel de l'histoire américaine
ici frédéric nicoloff radio canada
montréal